you've been brought into this whole
extreme like love triangle it's place
like a love hexagon that you're having
to deal with yeah is it hexagon or
octagon now I don't know how many people
has been changed but it's it's getting
bigger by the day walking about to come
with me judgment and today we are joined
by it be amazing that you have had one
of the most intense years but your life
has completely changed well it was
before he had loved islands you come out
you do all this insane stuff that's
going on how Spain been what you
expected it would be like not really
like I think from before I was in the
industry you just see the highlights you
see like the big events and like getting
glammed up and they're like deals and
stuff like that it's like when I started
working with pretty little Phoenix oh oh
my god my dreams come true that's it but
you don't see the negative patrolling
that everyone's opinion on literally
everything you do ever it's like a work
job whether it's a relationship choice
whatever it is you're going to be
criticized by all angles so that at
first was a lot to deal with but I think
you learn as you go on like you change
with it I've definitely like grown a
hard to skin and just feel like I'm
different now what do you think you've
learned about yourself in the last year
would you say I feel like I'm definitely
stronger than I thought I was coming out
when after the final we get taken into a
press office and they'll tell you like
write this story this story they're
stories come out and are saying well I'm
just going to stay here like that's not
go back to reality but it's not until
you're you're having to deal with that
and you're in amongst all of these
stories and people's opinions and
people's judgement on like I say every
move you make you don't realize how hard
you are and how strong you are as a
person and for me I think I'm 25 now if
I'm gonna make a choice it's to me if it
won't please everybody out there but as
long as me my family and close friends
are happy I'm happy
yes spirit because it has to be all
about you and where you get your own
validation from your validation comes
from within right yeah exactly
please everyone and what people see at
home or through Instagram or social
media is a small part of it they don't
see everything what would you say has
been the worst thing you read about
South by a troll probably for me about
my looks
prior to surgery because obviously I
wasn't content and happy with the way I
look so for me to go and make a change
and be open and honest about it like
there's count of celebrities that have
had little tweaks here and there and
never owned up to it and for me I think
as a young girl I looked up to all these
like perfect looking people or will in
society's world like perfect and no one
admits to surgery to me being given this
platform I think no I'm gonna say do you
know what when I was 13 I didn't love my
sticky-out ears I didn't love this and I
changed it and if you want to do that
and you're happy to do that don't feel
afraid to say that because it's like you
get penalized for not having surgery and
then when you go and take them steps
then you get penalized because you're
fake plastic you know like that was what
really hurt me it was like the guy that
I left a villa where does that wait
until he sees the real you it's like I'm
a 14 year old child in these pictures
like how can you ridicule a 14 year old
child it's so sad do you feel like you
still carry around that 14 year old
child with you of course that's my
biggest thing two young girls like I'm
happy with the choices are made with
cosmetic surgery but at 19 I went in was
the view that right I'm gonna get in
large breasts I'm gonna have my nose
done and I'm gonna come out and I'm
gonna be so confident and sassy unless
you learn to love yourself all you're
changing is the outside show so that's
my biggest message to young girls but
these trolls they they know that deep
down you're still this insecure young
girl who's like doesn't love the way she
looked and although I've changed outside
shell it took a lot of therapy a lot of
self-love age and all kinds of things
can make me really love myself so if you
could go back now and was the money you
spent on the same plastic surgery would
you put that into therapy instead and do
that first or how would you change it
maybe I was fortunate enough to do both
so I the first point of cool for me was
the boobs and the nose and then I
changed that and then I thought you know
I'm still not happy in like I said I'm
honest and open I was 19 I was naive and
I thought I'm gonna come out and be so
confident that wasn't the case the next
thing I got straight on the phone I've
got a fairy Pierce and I was just
talking about like why don't you love
this
from the troopers it's not about the
outside appearance it's about I don't
know what it is it's just like UV you're
like built with this self esteem while
you're not and I've always had low self
esteem but I think with age with pushing
myself definitely like love island strip
in all of that it's something that
naturally a shy insecure person wouldn't
do so to put myself in your situation
still grow it and you're proving to
yourself how strong you can be what's
the biggest lesson you've learned from
therapy it's the way you talk to
yourself so if on a daily basis you're
telling yourself negative things you're
gonna believe that the way you talk up
your friends and like no come on go you
bought this you can do this then you're
going to be confident I think I'm my own
worst critic so number one don't compare
yourself to anyone on social media
because that is a highlighted version of
someone's life and as cliche as it is
love yourself you've got to tell
yourself positive like affirmations in
the morning but like right you've got
this do not I mean I'm not a my own
worst critic so I think that was the
biggest journey I've come on in therapy
didn't speak kindly to myself why are
you out with your self-esteem now would
you say sitting in this chair today
where how are you would your self-esteem
in yourself I think at 25 I love myself
I'm not apologetic for any of my
previous choices in a sexual way in the
works way in any way I'm I'm a little
bit selfish but it's to make me happy
you only have one life and you've got a
little bit and I'm this mother Fleur yes
yes you are I think what's really
important as well as to remember when
the things that happen to you like
because I've got to know you quite a bit
over the last I say six months yeah and
the level of sexism that is pushed
towards you is extreme and we were just
talking about you know what the
relationship between you and where's
he's sort of seen this it's like golden
child almost then you're kind of
vilified probably just because of the
fact that you're women and that's how
society's been trained to thing
what do you think about that level of
sexism use face in the public eye would
you say to me obviously being in the
industries I've been in you kind of get
accustomed to being like no we're
exactly the same as men but all the
women I work with everyone in my circle
is of them mentality like women and the
same as
but for a lot of people out there it's
still very backward it's still like oh
women need to be all like sweet and
virginal and innocent and men can go out
and sleep with whoever they want so I
think slowly and surely for me the real
people that make mainly confident and be
able to speak help out was like Amy
Schumer and Burroughs all of these women
if they hadn't been so outspoken when
their platform say yeah we're a woman
but we enjoy sex just imagine island of
renounces I think in the UK it's still
very behind yeah taboo and in the US
people are more open about it there
shouldn't be any shame in it as long as
you're practicing safe sex enjoy it
strap on and go but also I think what's
really important is is that you've been
brought into this whole extreme like
love triangle it's placed like a love
hexagon that you're having to deal with
in a situation dream right now
yeah is it a hexagon or octagon now I
don't know how many people has been
changed but it's getting bigger by the
day but if you wanted to set the record
straight on it what would you want to
say to people about your experience of
being in that situation if you want to
tell the truth what would you want to
say as a woman or as a guide just trash
up anything if you know something is off
trust yourselves don't listen to anyone
else and I think it's so hard in any new
relationship trying to figure out what
the other person's priorities are are
they being completely honest with you
let alone when you're in the public eye
and every single person's got an opinion
so you know even yourself trust your
instincts and go ever got your instincts
been proved right in the situation
million-person yeah yeah is when you
read it on all these headlines and you
like I'll finally just like the truth is
out yeah it still stings because in my
in my heart I wanted not to believe it
and I I am very passionate and I did
speak out when I had these doubts and I
thought oh hopefully I'm wrong hopefully
it's just me being insecure whatever but
it turns out I was right the whole way
sir is I think a really important thing
to remember here is though when you came
out and you said those things that you
were Jose it's like we all do it what
all like we will go in to fight these
jealousy circles don't we where will i
oh my god he just like this person's
picture on Instagram did you like go
into that cycle as well there's
no one's gonna like their partner being
with another male female for 12 hours a
day like ten hours a day it's not ideal
especially you know new fresh
relationship so we went from being on a
TV show to them coming out and we had
noted you know what we missed all the
nice bit of data and we never went for
dates mean we went from zero to 100 we
was like in the villa with no stressors
no troubles to then being like an old
married couple living with each other
I've never lived with anyone he had
never lived with anyone so it's like we
skip the whole nice cute little bit like
the Nando strips Bay basically I would
say matters but yeah what are you
looking back at the insane year you've
had these extreme headlines and you're
looking forward to this new year this
new star like you just finished with
where's you've got fresh new star what
do you want to achieve next what do you
want - what do I find for me I've never
I didn't come up the phone and think
right money money money I'm gonna do
this deal about like hair extensions
this for me I was fortunate enough to
earn good money at like the age of 20 so
now at 25 I just want to do things like
this the campaign for brilliant mental
health I want to do more serious things
I'm done with reality I don't want to
let people in my personal life about
like relationships and stuff like that
I'd love to do documentaries I love and
obsessed will live through and Stacey
Dooley I'm a female Louie for a guy
literally wandering there you know when
he goes to like brothels and stuff I
would love it but because on a more
personal level I can relate to girls
that works and like strip clubs and
stuff like that I'd love to show my more
serious side cuz I am really intrigued
and interest and obviously I've lived
not the brothels but I've lived a little
part of it yeah you can say to someone
who's like you know might be a stripper
right now and they feel like they can't
get any escapes and they people can't
see them any differently what would you
want to say to those guys just oh man
and you don't have to explain yourself
to anyone and that was my biggest
problem at 20 I made this choice to go
and do it and I was so naive I never
stepped foot into a strip club before I
started working in one and I thought oh
it just be older men numbers
ever gonna find out of course everyone
in my local area found out and then I
had like hate left right and center and
I think as long as you're happy and
you're comfortable doing the job you're
doing do it you can't please everyone
and there's long as you're happy that's
the main thing I think it's so amazing
you can sit here and you can say that
stuff you can empower people and use
your platter in such an amazing way -
you're a peg thank you so much very very
credible
[Music]